哈囉大家好,我是虎哥
歡迎來到讓你越看越有錢的交易頻道
那講到基礎分析指標
可能大家會聯想到
它普遍存在延遲性的問題
也就是說容易錯過一大段行情
指標才產生訊號
為什麼這款指標會如此強大的原因
都要歸咎於市場的一個慣性
價格漲跌是由成交量所推動的
那大家最常聽到的基礎指標
像是MACD、RSI、KD等等
都是由這些價格基底所計算出來的
那這款OBB人量潮指標呢
是以推動價格之前的成交量作為指標
形成判斷的依據喔
因此就可以在指標延遲前知道市場的脈絡
造就市場有一句經典的名言
新手看價老手看量
因此呢成交量在我們進場之前
必須研究了重要指標
那接下來影片呢
會為你整理OBB指標裡面的
兩個交易核心重點
第一點
OBB指標特訊與目的
要做任何判斷之前
一定要清楚他能幫助我們解決交易上的什麼樣的問題
否則你懂再多的判斷方式
最終還是會失敗收場
因此我們要先清楚OBB指標的特性與目的
才能真正領悟到
OBB指標在實戰中三種最有價值的運用方式
我們要知道任何的判斷方式並不是追求準確性
而是在使用對的時機點才能發揮出最大的成效
那接下來虎哥要講的重點非常重要喔
記得按下訂閱並開小鈴鐺
才不會錯過虎根每週更新的交易乾貨喔
最後影片我會教你如何辨識機構大戶進場的時機點
就能及時搭上順風車掌握到最關鍵的派發行情
第一點,OBB指標的特點與目的
從它的公式計算裡就可以一目瞭然
就是它與成交量之間密不可分的關係
在指標中顯示的OBB值
是以累積成交量的形式做計算
意思就是指說今日收盤價高於前日收盤價
OBB就會處於正值
反之今日收盤價低於前日收盤價
OBB就會呈現負值
而如果今日與前日收盤價持平就不會做計算
因此就會以正負值增減做累積
表現出OBB形成的曲線
那我們用日線作為計算週期
計算公式是當日OBB值等於本日OBB值加前日OBB值我們就可以看到他都是以成交量做計算那OBV就被称为是个领先与价格的指标为什么学会OBV指标
可以让你提前发现到机构大户的中绩呢
因为机构大户进场一定有成交量
这个是机构大户无法隐藏的
所以我们只要找到量
就能找到机构大户的中绩
OBV的指标在真实的盘面里
首先我们先打开TV
然后搜寻OBV指标
它跟以往的指標不太一樣,就是因為它不用設置參數
這有一個很大的優勢,就是不會對於參數值的高低有效果的差異性
而上面看到的這個長度設置,是在指標之前要搭配運用時才需要做顯示
而我們這次知道針對OBB運用的進行解析
所以像是MA或其他長度設定就不影響使用,所以我們不需要理會它
那我們這邊OBV可以很直觀的看到
它就是一條單一的曲線圖
而且走勢和圖表上的K棒其實有點相似
在這個OBV裡上面有個高峰
圖表裡也就是出現一個高峰
那如果指標出現低谷
也會很明顯看到低谷
因此成交量與價格兩者之間的關係
在實戰運用中將會是關鍵的訊息所在
那接下來第二點
OBV指標實戰運用中最有價值的運用方式
任何的技術指標判斷
會因為你運用時機點不同產生的判斷
目的也就有所不同
於是我統整了三種OBV運用方式
針對我們的交易策略所缺乏的進行補足
去優化我們的交易系統
那我們這邊要注意的是
OBV是以成交量的變化所形成
所以我們的交易系統裡會去看更高時間大週期來做運用
而非小時間週期
那我們先說到第一種運用方式
就是利用OBV確認趨勢來提高獲利空間的用法
那我们这边循序渐进的先了解它的判断方式
再带入图表来进行运用
我们个人就非常清楚它使用的流程来达到良好的运用效果
当发现OBB曲线与价格同涨同跌时
就能表示趋势得到确认
如果OBB创新高价格也跟着创新高
就表示上升趋势将持续上行
如果OBB值创新低价格也创新低
这个下跌趋势也就持续下行
那這時候我們沿著OBV指標的方向進行操作
不僅更加安全也提高行情的增長空間在圖表裡我們可以看到圈起來的位置形成當時OBV的高點是我們對照上方的K棒被OBV的成交量推動者因此讓K棒價格也形成高點
那這時候我們就可以確認趨勢將會持續向上運行
因此我們就以多方的策略來進行交易
反之我們看到圈起來的部分形成當時OBV的低點
而對照上方的K棒也形成低點
這時候我們就能確認趨勢還會持續向下
因此我們就會以空方策略來進行交易
所以如果說你不知道該如何判斷趨勢方向
你就能利用這款OBV判斷方式
簡單直觀地做辨識
第二種運用方式是辨識趨勢改變的關鍵時機點
當OBV指標創新低
但價格卻沒有創新低
代表價格與指標產生背移的情況
就會出現了強烈的多頭訊號
行情就會從下降趨勢轉變為上升趨勢
那如果說OBV指標創新高,但價格卻沒有創新高的情況下
這時候產生的背離表示空投訊號,也就表示方向轉變的關鍵所在
所以我們圖表裡可以看到,下方OBV的指標裡
第一個圈起來的地方與第二個創新低圈起來的位置
但價格卻沒有創新低,反而價格低點是變高的
而這就是產生背離的現象,行情也就從下降趨勢轉變成上升趨勢
因此這時候你持有空單交易,你就會選擇出場轉變為多頭策略
相反的OBB指標裡,我們第一個圈起來的高點與下一個圈起來的高點有創新高
然後對照上方的K棒,第一個圈起來的高點以及第二個圈起來的高點並沒有創下新高點
也就產生背移的現象
因此這時候如果手上持有多單交易,就會選擇出場轉為空單策略為主
而我們可以看到往後的行情呈現下降趨勢的運行
因此對於交易時還不了解趨勢是否轉變方向
上升與下降趨勢之間相互轉換的訊號
你就可以利用這一個方法來辨識
再來就要說到如何辨識機構大戶進入市場
來掌握關鍵的派發時機
也就是第三點
如何在震盪後的第一個時間找到多空強勢的動能
那這時候我們就能利用OBV以量能帶動價格的特性
让行情处于震荡时
对于趋势发出动能的时机
提供了很关键的讯号
也就是当价格出现震荡OBV指标在往后的曲线向上突破區間壓力時就表示多方動能湧入買漲做多的訊號
而價格處於震盪
OBV指標在期間向下跌破這個區間震盪時
就表示進場做空的訊號
而我們圖表裡可以看到
左邊直線到右邊直線之間
價格處於震盪走勢
而對照下方的OBV
我們用水平線拉出震盪期間的高地位
然後往後OBB向下穿過下方的水平線時
這時候我們可以作為空方動能的湧入
也就是進場做空的訊號
而往後的行情我們也看到持續向空頭走勢運行
相反的當價格處於震盪、高點與低點的水平線
往後穿過上方水平線時
這時候我們就可以作為多方動能湧入
買漲做多的訊號
但我們要注意的是任何指標的運用都要有個觀念
就是不能單獨做使用
而是要滿足其他條件才能作為進場時機
因此這時候我們就要留意K棒
這時候是否符合空轉多反轉訊號
這表示指標多方動能的勇度
與K棒的訊息是一致的
因此我們看到圈起來的地方
現在是空方後形成盤整產生多方訊號
這就是標準的反轉
這表示當時指標的多方動能將持續帶動價格上漲
那往後行情也是如期快速上漲
那如果說我們忽略掉K棒的價格運用
指標產生進場訊號就貌然進場的情況下
很容易產生向下回調的情況
造成買在近期高點的結果
因此這部影片我們可以看到
OBB針對不同的目的所運用的時機點不同
因此我們可以遵照我們的交易策略
如果要確認趨勢往後是否有動人
你就可以使用第一種運用方式
確認趨勢是否會持續運行
如果是想辨識趨勢方向是否改變
則可以使用第二種虎哥剛講的方式
來辨識趨勢是否轉變的關鍵時機
而第三種方式是可以在機構大戶湧入交易量時
跟隨大戶進場的腳步輕鬆掌握派發的交易機會
虎哥希望你能透過OBB指標
幫助你更直觀的辨識市場的變化
在影片中虎哥講到的重點有幫助到你
也麻煩在這部影片點個讚
並且分享給你有在交易的朋友
最後如果還沒有訂閱虎哥的朋友們
現在按下訂閱並開啟小鈴鐺
感謝朋友們的支持
我們下一集見
各位拜拜